there's a chapter
uh an ipython notebook
which is much more much more detailed
explanation of
kind of my research into this area um
so i've put that on the web it reads
kind of like a book chapter i was going
to originally write a
um a book a book with this is an
inclusion
um so i did that i've been inspired by
the um
bayesian um hackers um bayesian for
hackers
the cam davidson pilon he pushed out his
sort of sort of book as a github
repository and it's brilliant because
it's just an ipython notebook and he
hasn't made any
sort of play that he's going to actually
put out as a book but it's a great idea
just to push out ipython notebooks
because
obviously everybody does every everybody
knows why i picked the notebook
everybody there without we're all okay
we all understand that
so what i've got is i've got an ipython
notebook which you can put as
you can put as a gist and you can stick
on github
and then it just comes as a static
document so that i've linked from my
website to that
i've got a live document an ipython
notebook that covers this as a kind of
chapter
a bit more detail and what i've done now
is i've pulled off
the um what i see is the kind of meat of
what we need to talk about today
so what so i've been through this once
before it takes about 45 minutes
so what i've done as well is this note
this is a ipython notebook that's been
transformed
using the ipython notebook slideshow it
gets longer
they put more things on the end of it
and so that's available
as both an ipad and notebook and
as html so that's everything covered so
you sh
it's like you tell you've got a lot of
take home with this particular
discussion so the only thing is
i just have to keep my eye on it nobody
can see this bottom corner but this is
the kind of controller
so i have to sort of bend over and
control it this way
so my name is jonathan edwards um johnny
edwards
i've got a small consultancy in um in
newcastle
um if everybody if you don't know where
that is it's a long way that way just
near the borders of scotland
and um i've been doing bits and bobs
around
data science and machine learning for
the past while the business has been
going a couple of years
so i was interested in
initially in um i'll just talk about
initially interested in recommender
systems not from
a um we'll talk about the idea of users
and items
which is the predominant sort of area
for recommender systems
that's not what i was doing to start
with i was actually looking at proteins
and compounds so how you
might get proteins and compounds to kind
of um
how you might build a matrix of proteins
and compounds and how you might infer
activity between compounds and proteins
so my date
actually the little bit of data that
you'll see that i've graphed up is
actually a little portion of a protein
compound
matrix a interaction matrix
so this is what so i did that work and
then i kind of wanted to take a step
back and wanted to fill in a few gaps in
my own understanding
about some of the different techniques
because the there seems to be kind of
nomenclature problems
in this area people call svd one thing
they call there's svd plus plus there's
there's all kinds of different things i
wanted to sort of like collaborative
filtering gets used as a kind of
whole whole terminology when i kind of
see it as a little bit
so i want to kind of put my own sort of
classification on the techniques and
what i want to do is
really classify them in terms of the
principles they use
rather than specifically the names of
the techniques so what i'm hoping
it's a novice level talk i'm hoping to
give you an understanding
of the problem of making a recommender
system uh i want to give you
a headline as to the kind of guiding
approaches
and then we're going to look at some
python there's not
actually much there's a small bit of
numpy which is the only real
um bit of code that i've written the
rest of it is really libraries
and that's the say you know the the
great thing about python is
it's normally been done before by
somebody who knows about it a lot better
than you
so and then there's a few shortcomings
of these approaches
um which people don't often sort of sort
of
tout about they sort of keep that to
themselves really
and i don't want you to go away thinking
that the recommender systems is a kind
of solved problem
and you don't need to do anything you
just need to fire up some code and
that's it but
um what i want you to go away with is a
set of tools that if you are going to
approach this problem you know how to do
it and you know some of the ins and outs
of some of the variables
one thing i try and drives all of my
work is the idea of does do things seem
sensible so
when we look at the data i urge you to
look and say well do those numbers seem
right do they seem something that i can
understand
so so that's that so if you want to
follow this these are the libraries that
i pull in
most of them are in the um whatever it's
called anaconda
but mpl tools are nympha and sparse svd
they're not there so i pulled everything
in via pip
which probably means my machine is
infected by i don't know
there was that pip thing wasn't there
about six months ago
i don't know do people know that do you
know about that
yeah everything's everything's on my
website but i'll put it on github as
well
um thoughtfultech.co.uk so it's all it's
all linked up
so what's the problem that we're trying
to do we're trying to we're in
in in the sort of traditional setting
we're trying to
make it look at what users do and look
at what items do so
the traditional setting for this is
something like amazon so if you've all
seen the recommended assist
the recommended kind of bar of amazon
that said people who bought this do this
and companies are interested in that
because it affects the margins and they
want to be able to make
good judgments because they don't want
they don't want to email people
kind of wrongly chosen items
or email the wrong person so the idea is
to try to understand the underlying
purchasing behavior of the customers
they've got
and by purchasing behavior i also mean
the underlying properties of the items
that they've got as well
so we're kind of trying to figure out
what we're going to do
with items and with users um again i've
i've written it here
so we can recommend products and so we
can look at maybe stock levels there's a
whole host of things you can do once
you've got this
idea so the best way of thinking about
this and the kind of guiding
sort of structure for all of this is a
matrix and the type of matrix we have
is this so this is my family
they're my family and these are what
they do they drink ginger beer
and lemonade and occasionally we drink a
lot of champagne in our house which is
really nice
um so this is a user item matrix so
my sister julia's bought three bars of
chocolates
and my daughter rosa who's ten has drunk
six bottles of champagne
so um so that's the kind of matrix and
we you'll notice that there is blacks
blanks
i haven't put zeros in deliberately
we've got kind of blanks where we don't
know what's going to happen
we don't know people haven't done
anything so we don't know
so they're up for grabs they're the
areas that we need to look at
one thing to do well i'll show you this
first
the so we can boil this down into kind
of an interaction matrix we've
interacted these two products have
interacted
this person this product has interacted
sorry and
that's just a binary version of that um
so what was i going to say so yes so
we've got this matrix
and we've got this idea that um
so one thing to do now this is what i
was going to say one thing to do now is
to just look and say right where would
what what would i do if i was having to
do this as a day job
and then somebody was giving me a matrix
and say where should we send our emails
where would i send my emails and
i i sort of think well karen looks a
little bit
like she is reluctant but she's bought a
little bit
but everybody else has bought all of
these products so
to my mind there's a sort of gap here
where you think
maybe people are going to do that and
these products look like they're selling
maybe this person isn't a buyer so this
is the sort of game that one plays with
uh
with recommender systems this idea of of
users and items and whether they've got
a propensity to buy or whether they
um whether the items have got a
propensity to sell
so certainly this item here
this person here is a heavy buyer ruby
my little daughter
she's a heavy buyer and these products
are heavy sellers
so it sort of stands to reason to sort
of to my mind they're the key areas
that when we do some analysis we look at
and we can gain some assurance
by looking at those and say oh yeah it's
doing something it's doing something
that i think is
is is sensible so that's the um
that's the matrix so that's at the start
that just pulls everything in
and there's two approaches there's two
kind of principles
there's many approaches but there's two
principles so the first principle is we
kind of do some kind of averaging
along the axis so we sort of say do you
know what this person's a bit like that
group
therefore they might do this so it's
trying to sort of
take the group behavior is
we know what's similar about somebody so
we know that if somebody's similar to
somebody else then the chances are the
difference is going to be
something that we can work with so again
we can do that
with products as well we can look at how
similar products are and
whether they're selling or not selling
or whether they sell to so that's the
idea so we're kind of taking the matrix
if i go back a slide
we're sort of saying on a row by row
basis
and we're sort of saying on a column by
column basis
okay so the second idea is a little more
sort of statistical and a little more um
i would say uh what's the best way of
putting it
i it yeah it's a little more sort of
process oriented
and that's the idea of a factor model so
the idea that you've got a latent factor
so the idea that
underlying this data is some kind of
decomposition
that will that drives the underlying um
activity of people and the underlying
activity of
of items so there are techniques for
both of these there are techniques for
collaborative filtering and i'm just
demonstrating a really
simple one today the latent factor
matrices
ideas the non-negative matrix
factorization and the singular value
decomposition
they're um they're the
they're the business in python you'll
see you can do it and you can do sparse
versions and
there's four libraries for it again not
linked from anaconda but
readily available via pip um and
you're in a a great world as python
users to do that kind of work
so let's look at
that let's look at this idea of
aggregation so what we're going to do is
we're going to take the k nearest users
we're going to take we're going to look
down the user list or across the items
i should have put users items and we're
going to look down the user list and
we're going to sort of aggregate them
into into similar sort of sets
and then we're going to calculate a new
vector based on this aggregation
function
so we're going to take them we're going
to find out what's close and by close we
have a
we have a k value you'll see that a lot
of these techniques have k
values um does everybody know what i
mean by k value
initialization variable that you have to
fiddle with to get the thing working
um so so underlying this is the concept
of distance and the concept of
things being together and being able to
figure out what what distance between
things means
and i've just taken a simple jacquard
distance measurements here if anybody's
ever kind of touched it it's um it's the
um
one minus the intersect over the union
so in this case we've got kind of
ten as the union and then we've got
intersections of
five ones so that's the jacquard measure
so you can use arbitrary measures the
this ac the idea of collaborative
filtering is quite general there are
if you look on particular on wikipedia
it gives you a general sort of algorithm
and there's lots of tuning that can be
done
around this particular approach
fortunately for you guys
a lot of the methods are really easy to
implement in numpy
and are very available inside pi so
so this is that i mean that's all the
code that you need to do a collaborative
filtering on users
it's it falls out really nicely and
this is what you start with we're just
initially we're looking at binary data i
tend to focus on
making predictions about where you're
going to find people
rather than how much they're going to
buy
mainly because that's the background in
sort of protein compound interaction
that i came
came from but so that's the code
this is the matrix that we started with
this is our prediction matrix so this is
x dash
so we'll see that it's not a million
miles different
we've got we're actually making some
zero predictions we're making where
are we we're actually sort of changing
that one
and we're making a prediction around the
ruby one here so we're not doing a
massive amount on this one
but we're making a few our predictions
now one thing you'll notice is some of
those
some of the ones have been made into
zeros so we're actually saying
we don't think somebody's going to be
there we don't think there's going to be
a sale there
so that's interesting what do you do
when you've got data that tells you
something that your model doesn't
predict well
in our approaches we always said data
trump's model
so that was the way it was
so we have the data trump's model idea
so that code all it did was it took the
matrix it took distances between
jacquard distances between
i'll go back actually explain that
so we took jack our distances for each
one of these down
in a group of three because k equals
three and then we aggregated those
groups
and then we replace the value with that
aggregate value
okay so does that make sense
what do we feel about that results well
the idea that a model is predicting
something that the data tells us
differently
is not great um we we don't like to see
that
we like to see models predicting data
that we already know about we like to
see that we don't like that
not happening that's not good um
obviously there's a lot of tuning that
can go in i didn't want to tune
i didn't want to present something i
wanted to present you with techniques
that kind of warts and all
so i didn't want to um tune it and the
easy way to
to do this the other way around is just
to flip the matrix
so what do we feel about collaborative
filtering well those results aren't
great
the idea seems interesting the idea
seems something that we can get our head
around
maybe something we can explain to our
bosses should we have to justify what
we're doing
um but we'll see there's there's other
ways of doing this
so is everybody familiar with the idea
of a latent model
we all got that background in our heads
we all understand what that means
hands up hands up if you no no
right so the idea of latent models is
the idea that
with any bit of data there is something
underlying driving it so there's
something behind the scenes
that actually we're better off looking
at we're better off looking at it
because it's
normally smaller and it's normally more
demonstrative of the data so it's less
it's it's a compression
it's more of the data there's less um
there's there's uh
is the less entropy oh the same identity
but the um
so there's less there to play with and
and we and we're trying to get this
underlying driving force
so here's an example um that
i use in the book the idea that you
might represent the music band by
the year the band name the album name
the sales and the rating
so we can already see well the band name
the album name doesn't really
mean anything it's actually sort of
somewhat superfluous so we've already
got some data that we kind of got a bit
of redundancy with
um so when i bought records when i was
a grunge guy in 1991 i'm probably
showing my age now
when i bought records you know it was
grunge and that's what i was buying i
was in the 90s and i was buying
nirvana and pearl jam and things like
that so
um so this data the
never mind album which sold 30 million
copies and i guess this
i i guess that number which is amazing
and then looked it up on wikipedia and i
got it right
so that's really good so that number or
underlying number
um doesn't actually mean a lot all that
i was really interested
in was this idea that it's a 90s grunge
band and i'm probably still this
i've been through dance and i'm back
into grunge that's my little journey in
music i went through dancing out and
so at one point it was a 90s dance and
then it was
back into grunge as i got older and a
bit more sort of stayed in my ways
but they're the latent factors it's a
really interesting thing it's a really
interesting idea what is it behind the
data
now the problem with this description is
we've got names for them we know what
they are
we go yeah that's your latent model and
that's the problem with later models is
there's not often a set of names
there's not often a way of going showing
someone saying do you know what we found
out that
people buy roses on valentine's day you
know or something like that there's not
often
that kind of nice description oh the the
model this
this is what happened it it often
doesn't happen and lots of latent models
are set up
so that it's actually quite complicated
to get back back to that so we don't
know what's going on
and indeed you'll see with these we just
have an arbitrary bunch of numbers
so so this idea of latent models is not
without its weaknesses
it'd be nice to have some technique that
got you the late model and
explained it all for you that would be
lovely somebody needs to work on that
one but there's this whole issue of
causality and
all the kind of things that people guys
statisticians
get quite keen about but what we're
trying to do in this next set is try and
figure out later models
so there's two techniques
there's more than two techniques but
there's two techniques that are readily
available in python
and interesting one of this one of the
ideas is to use a matrix we've got a
matrix of data so we're going to use a
matrix decomposition
and we use a decomposition of the dot
product all that means is we're kind of
linearly
because the dot product is the addition
of the multiplication
then we're just um linearly sort of
modeling this thing and we're taking a
night a set of data for the
um the users and a set of data for the
the items and we're saying how can we
model those two things
how can we have two matrices that are
sub matrices of our big matrix
that we multiply together forming our
big matrix how can we get some two
really small versions of those
that really encapsulate all there is to
know about the data
so so that's what happens with a with a
non-negative matrix factorization you do
a decomposition
down into two matrices there are
there are lots of things to do with the
formation of these matrices
and there are lots of methods i think in
the nympha library that i
link to in this talk there's ten methods
there's probabilistic methods there's
bayesian methods it's been around
it's it's fairly mature sort of
technique although interestingly not the
machine learning guys
like murphy the people who publish the
big probabilistic books they tend to
give it
quite short shrift actually that you
know there'll be a big chapter on
on topic modeling but then this is you
know that this is often quite a small
sort of
aside i don't know whether they don't
like the idea or one
we'll see there's one reason why you
might not like the idea but
so note that we pick a k again so we we
normally pick the same well obviously we
pick the same size k so we're trying to
try to make them smaller and we're
trying to make this k k small
such that it represents the data but it
doesn't
um totally represent it's not a it's not
an
it's not totally there is some
compression going on
so how do we find umv and um
and then what do we do once we've got
that well the best
the best way is um there are several
techniques there is um
they're all optimization based or
sampling based
and they're all in a lot of them like i
say are implemented in nympha
and it's an iterative optimization
problem we try to optimize we know some
gradients so we know
directions to head down there are
various discussions about which is the
better method
but nympha implements them all and it
implements a binary version as well
which is really good the best page which
is
linked to here it gives you a very good
explanation of the
iterative optimization very very good
uh explanation so
so let's get on with the code
so we've got the nympha library it's not
a readily well known library i don't
imagine any has anybody ever heard of
that library
before here it did come out of a summer
of code
type situation and it came out of
academia so it's not a commercial
library it's
it's open source and
it's not readily linked to but to my
mind there there are some matrix
factorization methods in psychic learn
but i've decided because i wanted a
rounder sort of version of it
was to um to stick with the nympha
library
there's extensive documentation and the
guys have done a really good job there
um you know you know well done
for that so all we do
is we run a method we give it a rank we
have some iterative
method and maybe a thousand is too high
um
and then we we iterate around and again
we we're not getting massive changes but
you'll see we're making some predictions
where data isn't
we're making a that's the one that
you've you've kind of bought a lot here
you've bought a lot here
so that one seems like a sensible
prediction
the um the other predicted area is here
we've got a one here
uh can't it's running in the middle
i rerun this so um we've got some
difference here
oh no we've got a one there so we're
making so we're making these specific
predictions about areas that we see that
we can sell to so
what we would do as a a website or
whatever it is
we would target those customers okay so
the
so the code is really simple the only
thing is we
have a slightly strange nomenclature for
the two like two
the two um latent matrices
so that's fine we make a prediction that
way
so that's that's matrix factorization
there is a
there is a binary matrix factorization
as well
bmf and we iterate less on that
uh and again we we're making some
predictions
we're actually not made so i don't think
i've ever optimized this one i think i
need a bigger rank to make some some
better positions
but i wanted to highlight is there is
this little game that you play with the
k value
that's what i said earlier was this idea
of a k value and this idea of setting it
such that
you don't reproduce the matrix totally
but you don't kind of destroy it and not
return anything that you know is right
so you want to produce all of your data
make some predictions
and um make some predictions but not
kind of destroy
you know make the later models so small
that you're not making any
anything sensible there's nothing there
basically
so again this is the nympha method and
we pull this in and it's fairly
straightforward
um to implement so so that's
that's three methods we've done already
so if somebody comes to you and say i
want to recommend the system
you know what i want you to go away
from this talk with is to say i can do
that you know i can i can have a first
stab at that
without a lot of hassle to be honest
just getting the data in that right
matrix format is
is a good starting point so that's so
we've covered collaborative filtering
we've covered the couple of
matrix factorization techniques um
the binary method is produces a specific
binary
factorization so it uses a slightly
different optimization
algorithm okay so here's the one
so i'm left thinking i'm not sure about
this and that's that's the way i look to
this day i was left thinking
i don't really know what k is and i
don't like that i don't like to
sort of have to guess k i don't i like
to have a bit more about to know a bit
more about things
because this k how does it affect in
this case it affects it quite heavily
because the matrix is very small
but on bigger matrix you know what do i
need do i need k of 327 do i need
it's if everybody if anybody remembers
the old neural network days when people
were building hidden layers and not
knowing how many i
how many um nodes to put in a hidden
layer you know there was
there was always that kind of discussion
about these k values and
anybody's ever done k means will know
exactly the same you know you're always
sort of guessing
i know there are ways out of that now um
in fact there is a probabilistic method
for this which i think uses sampling and
i think
builds k is integrates out k as a kind
of nuisance parameter
um but i haven't looked at those in
detail and i think they're quite timely
for large matrices
this is a kind of quick and dirty
approach
so some amazing questions do the results
look sensible well i'm still worried
that i'm not getting back what i've put
in uh how well does it scale you'll see
in my notes
that this technique doesn't scale as as
well as the next technique we're going
to talk about
is the answer unique no it's not so the
umv matrices can be significantly
different
and produce the same results uh there's
no
unique umv which to my mind is um is a
worry
and what about this initialization value
uh rank
what can i do about that well
i could take a bayesian approach and
integrate it out using sampling or
you know we're back to the kind of
guesswork world of of sort of data
science
guessing what we're doing okay
so here's my if i'm running this as a
horse race singular value
decomposition is my um front runner um
it's again a factorization it's a
special factorization that allows for
a kind of a scaling a rotational scaling
in a rotation
the middle matrix gives you some kind of
feel for
how how much value
there is in keeping a matrix of that
size so it it
it it extends out which is really really
important because once i know
roughly where k what k is doing
kb and the size of this diagonal then um
i can i can make some better predictions
i can use
this technique is also analytic um
so i get the same results every time i
think and
everybody knows it and it's been around
since i don't know when the first svd
was probably about 1830 or something
like that it's a
it's a very old mathematical technique
it's one of those techniques that people
just when they get they ah let's just
throw svd and see what happens
it's just one of those kind of do all
kind of techniques has everybody heard
of svd video it is a new idea to
a lot of people a new idea right
it gets latent semantic indexing has
everybody heard of latent semantic
indexing
no well it's the same similar sort of
approach you have a bigger matrix
but i urge you if you're doing this kind
of recommender get into this idea of the
singular value
it's got a lot of it's got a lot of
grounding and you'll see there are
people that were guys taking that a lot
further in the last five or six years
there are people really stepping up
and taking it even further so it's it's
a really sort of powerful technique
and the one important thing the one
thing that i really like because i like
plots
is it gives you something called the
elbow plot so we'll run through this and
i'll show you what an elbow plot is
so an elbow plot is it's kind of like
the power at different k's
right so it gives you how much how much
power you've got
to represent your matrix at a different
level so you can always plot this
in this case everything can be
represented quite easily around the kind
of two to three mark
it's called the elbow plot because you
if everybody if anybody's on pca it's a
similar sort of thing you look at where
this
where there is this turning point and
that gives you some indication of where
your data is
kind of where the power of the data is
where the where the actual data is and
where it isn't
so the elbow plot is really useful
for plotting that and for showing you
roughly what you should be
so that get to me that gives it a tick
in its box that's kind of you know
that that makes it a more powerful
technique because you've got this kind
of
window in on it windowing on what's
happening so again
it's a really easy call the svd library
is available in
scipy there are there are numerous svd
libraries available i think
at my last count there's kind of six
there are sparse versions there are
there are four sparse versions i think
there is pro pack
there is sparse svd there is another one
that i can't remember the name of
but there are there are lots out there
and they're all implemented in
they're not implemented in python
they're normally linking up to a lib
where somebody's done light lib svm
somebody's done lib sparse svd
so a really kind of a short bit of
coding the the svd inside
psi pi links to la pac or blas
or both actually something like that so
then you know these are really solid
bits of code
you're not going to really do a lot
better than that if you're implementing
the
yourself you're not going to beat blast
and lap they've been around for
for 20 30 years people optimizing those
out
so that's the great thing about python
is a lot of these old c libraries are
getting pulled in
and you're getting access to the proper
tools it's not like you're prototyping
you can actually start building proper
systems so let's look at
the the production
so this to me makes a lot more sense can
everybody see this
i'll put it a bit higher
so i've got so i've kept i think my k
was two
and i'm making some i'm still sort of
off but i'm i'm
being a bit more accurate i've made a
whole bunch of predictions here that i
didn't make in any other methods but
that was the kind of line that we were
interested in
we're interested in predicting this
bottom one
and we're saying we're not saying
they're going to do perhaps make us
do by as many as the full set but we're
certainly saying
she might buy one so we're making that
good prediction
and this seems more sensible it seems on
on small data where you're able to
eyeball it
it seems to make more sense so i'm sort
of happier with this technique on lots
of levels
i'm happier with it because it seems to
do something more intelligent
i'm happy with it because i've got the
i've got the box plot
the elbow plot and i'm happier with it
because i can
shell out to pro pack and i can get it
done in seconds
and i can represent this as a spa sparse
version
and i can do do do good things that way
so i'm a lot happier with this technique
so do the results look sensible well
to my mind having looked at a lot of
sets of results like this yes they do
does it scale yes it does is the answer
unique yes i think it is
i think it is pretty certain it is and
do i worry about this initialization
value this rank value well not so much
because i've got the elbow plot so it
ticks a lot of the boxes
so if i was to say to you guys you know
you've got a day to implement one of
these you've got some data
svd first protocol see what happens
okay so one issue that we've we haven't
so
we sort of haven't have a sort of um
subjective view of the data
so how do i know how well something is
doing
given that i don't know the results that
i'm supposed to be getting now this is a
big
question in the recommended community
and in fact it's been on quora and
everybody said how do i assess
because the key thing is if you just if
you've got some predictions that you've
made so you've got that matrix and
you've got values in it
and you um you say oh yeah i can do
really well at those values
actually you could do that in a binary
setting with a completely full matrix of
ones
you you could guess everything right by
just guessing everything so this idea
that you
you it's actually quite hard to judge
whether these systems are working or not
because
the latent model you don't know what's
happening you don't really know what's
happening with
the zeros because they're zeros so you
don't know how to treat them you don't
know whether to treat them as a single
zero or whether to treat them as a kind
of
an n a something that i haven't made a
prediction for so it's
it's an interesting little um it's an
interesting little idea
i was running my recommender against
another guy
who uh he had a system that just over
predicted
he just he had this bayesian system that
overpredicted and it really annoyed me
because he would get really good results
because he was just predicting
everything and he wasn't worried about
whether he was because we were just
using rms on the
on the individual values and he was he
was not
um he was not playing ball in my eyes
so i invented it so to to beat that
rather cheekily
i invented a another rms that took some
of the zero so this is the rms of all
the places where it's won in a binary
matrix
so we just take rms there and then we've
got this idea that some of the zeros
might actually be
zeros so let's just arbitrarily take
a bunch of those these matrices were
that we were dealing with were a million
by sixty thousand
so arbitrarily take a bunch of and they
were very sparse so i'm not taking a lot
of zeros
so arbitrarily take that bunch so i
invented this
sort of hack of a distance met a heck of
a
an rms measure that allowed me to kind
of beat him at his own game
so instead of getting better techniques
what i did was move the goalposts
so that was quite good but in all
seriousness the idea of judging whether
or not
recommender system is working or not is
it's not something that the community
the guy on quora said do a b testing
which you know implies that you've kind
of built it you stick it in front of a
set of users you see whether the users
are you know you'd use
so there was this idea of actually
running the whole system and then
figuring out what it's gone which
i thought was a little bit sort of far
down the line
so what i've got so what we've got is
we've got three techniques so far we've
got well we've got two principles two
meth two principles
and and three techniques that that that
we can use
we've got the collaborative filtering
models
we've got the um the major the
non-negative matrix factorization
and we've got the um this svd
so what i've done is i've taken one from
each side i've taken the the item
by item collaborative filtering and i've
taken the
um svd and run them against each other
on some data that's available on my
website
and the way i like to do this is with
the data
is to do it as an image so if you've got
big chunks of data you don't want to be
looking at the numbers
you actually want to be looking at
images so what i've done is
i take one image and i flip some bits
that i know are right
so if you look at that line there i've
got rid of all of that line virtually so
i just
wrote a little vectorized little flipper
that flips a few bits and
gets rid of a few of those so i know the
date is there
i knew the date it was there originally
i'm getting rid of it to run
um to run some kind of test on
my idea is again
what is sensible it'd be great if i
could fill in that little line there and
make those predictions again
so that idea would be really powerful
and you can see that
these areas are less i don't know maybe
less sparse
i've not flipped a lot of ones but
so that's that so what i'm going to do
is i'm going to run this
we're going to look at the images and
we're going to look at the rms values
and we're going to see
what happens obviously my
so there we go so one thing is you can
see how there's kind of homogeneity in
this so i'm
because i'm kind of averaging things we
get a more homogeneous sort of
set of data i've sort of made a bit of a
few predictions here
and my rms if just remember these
numbers is 0.14 and 0.48 for the sampled
rms
i think it's that way around so what
we're doing is we're trying to fill
these lines in really
so let's look at that let's look at our
second technique
which is svd we've got an elbow plot
and we look and and i i should have put
the two next to each other but we'll
notice that this line is a lot stronger
so we've made some predictions so that's
quite sort of magical really we're sort
of making predictions that we know we're
right
but we've we haven't got the data there
to start with we've used a later model
we've arbitrarily picked a k
and now yet we've got some results it's
quite good that
it's quite a good sort of setup you can
always find that if you're doing any
kind of machine learning
if you can kind of get a result by just
hacking a few bits together then you
know that you're on to
doing a really good thing once you start
really concentrating on what you're
doing
that's it seems to me if i run a project
and
something doesn't look like it's going
to go right from the start i
i've had to really fiddle things i've
had to fiddle okay gosh it's so
sensitive
then you know you're on a loser once you
try and tune it for real commercial
um implementation
so yeah both these scores are very
significantly down on this
on svd now i'm not i'm not being fair
here because this svd is a real kind of
production system you would implement
this
the collaborative filtering method
firstly it would be slow
and secondly you would probably you
would probably look at more
sophisticated sort of aggregation
functions
um but then again i'm i'm
i'm pretty close with a good um with a
good uh
with a good k value so
yeah okay
so this is what you do to build one of
these systems you collect that matrix
you you choose your algorithm you build
your prototype
you optimize performance and then you do
the view so it's really simple
the one problem you have and the one
problem i find was this update
cycle because i'm getting new data in
i'm getting new data into the system
when do i update it i've got to run the
model again and particularly if it's
something that takes
you know you're getting data every week
and the model takes a week to run
one implementation of this i had took
two weeks to run
so that was on a very big non-sparse
matrix
that so that's an issue but with sparse
svd you're not in that little space
because you've got
i can i can do big matrices in seconds
providing they're fairly sparse so
you've got the one thing i would say is
this idea of the update policy is make
sure you know what you're doing
when your data does data from model and
when does that all happen
okay so there is this this is looks like
magic that result that we got
with that data where we filled in the
line we had no prior knowledge about
that line
it's good it is clever you know we would
have sent the right emails to the right
people
um but there's sort of a magic there's a
magic to both approaches this idea of
late models is
is he's always been one of those things
in in
statistician circles that you know
they they sort of talk about whether you
know there's there's causality and all
the
the issues associated with sort of sort
of underlying models
um there is one thing that
you should be aware of you need a lot of
data
so the more data obviously the more data
you have the more um
the better the results you're going to
get because the more
kind of rank the more power you've got
in your data set so
that that was kind of that kind of that
sort of thing and this whole matrix
thing is being played out
in in something called the comment can
sensing community which is this big idea
that people have got about
instead of sensing full data sets
we actually do something clever and we
sense we subset
a full sense the example is in in an
image that you're taking up from a
camera you take a very large image and
then you compress it down into jpeg
well why bother taking the large image
in the first place why not
miss out that middle large image and go
all the way around it
and go from a sensed environment
to a compressed environment directly and
there's some great results there's some
great work being done in that area
and and that that has implication for
some of the factorization techniques
and some new factorization techniques
there's there's new robust methods
coming out that are just
quite new and do very interesting things
particularly if you're in the kind of
vision circles they do very interesting
vision
um sort of background subtraction and
things like that
and that's all being played out very
nicely with this guy in
france who's got this website called new
eat blanc
which is um he does all the
factorizations and he's got a big list
of all the factorizations that go on
and he's a really smart guy and he keeps
up to date it's a great way of keeping
up to date with what's going on in that
field
he just keeps it up to date for you you
just log in there it is
so that's all being played out the whole
rank the whole rank idea of
svd and the whole power and how much
data i need
just to actually make predictions on a
sort of large range
is all being sort of played out and
there are actually sort of sensible
little rules of
not even rules of thumbs quite sort of
practical sort of terms that people are
sort of playing out now
and the guy is candice emmanuel candace
at caltech
okay so there is this problem so we're
not without problems we've got to choose
k
and we've got to sort of know that we've
got enough value in our data to get
somewhere sensible
okay so i'm just a bit of a foot soldier
the the guys that have done all the big
stuff are the guys that have done
even the guy that did the ipython
notebook and things like that they're
all the big guys they're
i'm just a workaday python guy these
guys are the guys that are making the
difference the people who are writing
them
saipai numpai this makes a huge
difference to everybody else's life so
the python community is absolutely
awesome for that just it's just the best
i'm so loving not doing r anymore it's
just
so much nicer it upsets more people but
so that's it